hello America because of you my father
is now the president of the United
States
[Music]
real tears are character tears no one
knows that's how great of an actress I
am surprised I'm not a vodka Trump I'm
grace Helbig and you're on my youtube
channel right now and I thought this was
a really funny idea for a video maybe it
didn't come off that funny I have to
watch this back I have yet to determine
my opinion on this this is just such an
insane time in the state of the entire
world and it just reminds me that all
humans are humans and the only thing
that we are in control of as humans is
our ability to treat other human beings
with compassion consideration kindness
and respect a lot has come to light in
the last few days a lot of really
negative things but the most amazing
thing is to see in reaction to all the
negative all the positive wonderful
people that exist in the world and
that's where I plan to focus my energy
and my time on the people that make
positive change if you're afraid or you
feel alone or you feel confused there
are a lot of outlets that you can reach
out to if you feel alone some of them
are included in my description box below
so that's it that's it that's it but
look I tried soap guys I spent like
20-30 minutes doing this Ivanka Trump
hairstyle and makeup didn't work